E aí
Olá boa noite nós estamos aqui é Unidos
no Teatro Carlos Gomes no auditório
visível monte de vocês aqui
provavelmente não sabe quem foi visível
Assim como nós não sabemos a maioria das
pessoas que estão por trás dos nomes das
ruas normal
visível para os blumenauenses de até os
40 anos está associado ao nome de uma
loja o pessoal mais velho de toda a
região Blumenau Pomerode e Timbó visível
foi um lojista um dos mais reconhecidos
respeitáveis lojistas da região ele teve
uma loja com até 200 funcionários em
determinado momento e vende praticamente
de tudo no atacado e no varejo
Além disso visível Era Um Homem de
Família ele tinha uma grande família com
site feliz às vezes de hoje
novamente essa pessoa não faria mais
muitas coisas a não ser cuidar da
família e da loja certo pouco tempo bom
visível nasceu em Blumenau em 1903 e foi
dos anos 20 aos anos 50 um fotógrafo
entusiasta de imensa produção hoje em
dia nas eleições catalogando o material
e 52 eles cobram o cinema amador ao
comprar uma filmadora bolex 16mm
de 52 ele começa então uma
vertente de do documentarista ele
registra a história de onde quer que ele
passe
de os 52 até meados dos anos 80 e em
meados dos anos 80 ele tinha oitenta
anos de idade é importante lembrar
também que com cinema analógico uma
produção de qualquer filme levava meses
entre a filmagem Revelação
edição montagem e finalmente a exibição
e além de tudo isso pelo seu amor às
Artes seu visível que foi um dos membros
da diretoria desse teatro por quase duas
décadas
É eu sei tanto sobre o seu visível por
motivo Óbvio visível era o meu avô
e a maior que minha maior referência na
vida
e eu descobri recentemente infelizmente
após a morte dele um dos motivos de eu
acredito que o maior motivo dessa grande
paixão dele pelas Artes educação
E essas imagens que estamos vendo são os
cadernos de colégio do meu avô na época
que ele tinha entre 8 e 11 anos de idade
isso é em torno de 1914 100 Anos Atrás
Vocês conseguem imaginar a precariedade
de recursos na época
Já tentaram era muito mais caro e ainda
assim a gente consegue perceber o
cuidado esmero com a formação artística
dos jovens Então fala que nós estamos
vendo um recado um recorte dos cadernos
dele somente mas obviamente isso
acontecia com todos os jovens
e hoje em dia nós temos o que cima
cuidado com a formação artística dos
nossos jovens as profissões ditas
artísticas são toneladas como um mal
necessário como arquitetura design e
estilismo publicidade os pais esperam
que os filhos venham dizer que eles vão
ser médicos Engenheiros
médicos Engenheiros advogados Qual é a
expressão que se espera de um pai quando
o filho vai dizer eu vou ser artista
você ator você músico
nós temos muito contraditório onde a
arte é louvada mas não é ensinada
nós sabemos que o estranho desconhecido
gera medo e afastamento Arce que nos
trouxe até a civilização atual é
considerada Marginal ainda hoje em dia
os holofotes estão todos voltados para
setores considerados mais produtivos
mais dignos pela sociedade bom faz uns 4
anos eu e mais dois amigos reservamos
apagar alguns desses holofotes e gerar
alguma balbúrdia a balbúrdia surgiu de
uma pequena coincidência ou do que eu
prefiro colocar com uma sincronicidade
três amigos afastados uns dez anos
depois da faculdade nos encontramos um
evento que chacoalhou os três para fora
da nossa zona de conforto para fora da
nossa comunidade
e o designer chileno Carlos Felipe
pesquisar organizam em Jaraguá do Sul em
novembro de2010 um evento que ver se
tornar lendário entre a população entre
a comunidade criativa do sul do país o
potencial criativo juntor um grande
grupo de profissionais de altíssima
reconhecimento nacional e internacional
e um grupo imenso de jovens em busca de
conhecimento e inspiração e exemplo
Oi de novo a simplicidade com ajuda dos
pequenos ajustes que eu Rafael Silveira
e Paulo Pires
quiséssemos a mesma oficina chamava
diário gráfico com o ilustrador carioca
Renato Alarcão
ilustrador gravador
encadernador de altíssimo nível
a 12 diz Renato colocou em nossas mãos
grandes chapas de resíduo de indústrias
gráficas e nos ensinou a transpor para
cima desse papel e no menu as técnicas
artísticas com as quais a gente nunca
tinha dado pela produção intensa e todos
os participantes da oficina estavam
enlouquecidos e ferver sidos trabalhando
ali em cima no final do segundo dia
temos avisar horta em todo o material
todo mundo escandalizados mas como
cortar o material cortamos Todo o
material e cada equipe saiu com um
caderno um compêndio que misturava as
obras e todos os que tinham participado
em novos fragmentos com novas leituras
saímos todos extasiados
terminado o curso conversamos Os Três
Amigos
O que nós vamos fazer com isso estamos
aqui Asus
assombrados vamos voltar porque a gente
estava sem nessa criativa cada um
produzindo suas encomendas nos seus
escritórios ou gente vai dar um outro
andamento vamos dar continuidade esses
três dias depois da oficina numa
quarta-feira 17 de novembro estávamos os
três nos reunindo pela primeira vez no
porão lá de casa de novo uma
sincronicidade um cliente havia acabado
de deixar comigo para doação meses de
grandes formatos que eram perfeita para
nossas necessidades
é uma outra simplicidade triste a minha
avó Vitória usa do pav
a recém falecido e deixado uma coleção
imensa de publicações alemãs que ela
assinava que datavam da década de 20 até
a década de 90
dessas publicações nós tiramos
inspiração exemplos de caligrafia e
muitos recortes para colagens esse
material ainda dura até hoje pois era um
volume muito grande
é a ideia era manter a criação Lívia
furada como alargar um tênis ensinado
arte pela arte a
catálise artística soltar os nossos
Bichos em cima do Papel
acontece que essa ideia não era só nossa
aos poucos alguns amigos e algumas
desconhecidas
descobriram ouviram falar viram alguma
coisa no Facebook desse encontro de
Malucos Artes num porão da cidade e
começaram a surgir umas dois mais três e
nós percebemos que movimento começaram a
mudar e vezes e são a diversão onde nós
tomávamos refresco como O Petisco e uma
boa música enquanto desenhava vamos a
coisa começou a aumentar e com a chegada
de outras pessoas começou a surgir
cocriação o compartilhamento de técnicas
e estilos o aprendizado entre nós o
ensino informal o ensino
orgânico entre nós dentro do atelier
e com crescimento disso alguns sinopse
sofrendo pelos Russos e ampliar o
alcance das nossas Artes que até então
estavam confinados dentro do Ateliê
alguns lambe-lambe começar a aparecer na
cidade com intervenções artísticas outro
críticas sociais outros com críticas
políticas
extensos começaram a pipocar E com isso
mas gente Tomou ciência da balbúrdia e
mais gente começou a gravar bolha
eu conheço de novo com o crescimento
houve uma nova ânsia por mais
conhecimento e nós abrimos O atelier
para que outras pessoas pudessem vir
trazer novas técnicas novos estilos
novos pensamentos
o xilógrafo fotógrafos agora eles
começaram a ocupar o nosso espaços
a essas ocupações uma delas foi
extremamente frutifica pois
a Dilma aula se juntou um novo grupo e
forma um novo coletivo um coletivo
chamado libertos que tem pouco mais de
um ano e meio dedica-se à produção
fotográfica e um ano e meio de produção
já está na sua terceira exposição Esse é
um dos focos principais do grupo
expandir a produção de arte o máximo
possível e ao mesmo tempo comentar
catalisar novos grupos quanto mais
grupos pipocar em melhor
nós temos quatro como os principais
enfoques do grupo o primeiro Justamente
esse da multiplicação da expansão das
capacidades individuais pelo trabalho
coletivo cada um de nós ensinando os
outros o que sabe melhor e aprendendo o
que os outros fazem melhor mas isso não
de uma forma rígida formal para
estabelecida esperando o resultados
idênticos ou reproduções do que foi
ensinado bem pelo contrário a pouco um
amigo trabalhava com penas caligráficas
e ensinou e os movimentos essa em vez de
trabalhar com caligrafia ou só fazer
desenhos com aquilo o resultado que
ninguém tinha visto antes então é bem
isso nós procuramos essa essa
organicidade na informação na
comunicação no ensino
a segunda questão é a questão da autoria
hoje nós vivemos num mundo onde o autor
o seu ego é muito maior e várias vezes
do que sua obra muitos artista trabalha
com assistentes produzindo E ele
simplesmente ensinando a balbúrdia isso
não acontece toda a produção feita no
Ateliê nas atividades do atelier e é
assinada pela balbúrdia quer tenha sido
ela produzida por um grupo de pessoas ou
por uma pessoa só porque mesmo que
produzida por uma pessoa só ela foi
produzida numa atmosfera onde a
inevitável a comunicação de estilo
técnica cultura referência isso flui
naturalmente entre as pessoas então a
obra não é mais uma obra individual a é
uma obra coletiva
é o terceiro aspecto é o aspecto do
paradigma da posse do domínio todos os
valores sabem que o que é produzido na
balbúrdia é da balbúrdia não é mais do
criador é parte de todos eles Então ele
continua tendo Talvez uma ou talvez não
aí continua tendo uma fração daquilo Mas
ela é de todo mundo é um trabalho que
algumas pessoas têm que fazer nós já
tivemos amigos que vieram na primeira
vez e só olharam eu não vou conseguir
fazer e deixar e logo depois se abriram
e conseguiram permitir isso
E essas peças tem dois destinos as
exibições as encadernações as peças que
ficaram muito bem na sua integridade no
tamanho grande ou que por técnica ou
artisticamente ficaram muito boas elas
são separadas mas muito mais Faces
estudos testes ou peças que não precisam
manter essa sua integridade são fatiados
como elas estão ali fatiadas no chão
para gente selecionar e transformadas em
cadernos e esses cadernos sim cada um
dos balbúrdias nem sabem no normalmente
no final do ano um pequeno caderno onde
a fragmentos e toda a produção de todo
mundo então ele volta a ter voz não das
suas peças Mas sim das peças de todo
mundo que está lá
é o quarto aspecto é o aspecto da
retroalimentação a sociedade nós somos
um pequeno um pequeno grupo que faz
parte de uma sociedade maior e nós
achamos muito importante
o diálogo com a sociedade não a forma
mais democrática ou dinâmica do que
levaram as artes as ruas então alguns
membros do nosso grupo continuam levando
áreas degradadas da cidade um pouco de
surrealismo um pouco de questionamento
um pouco de alegria um pouco de água e
e é muito importante para nós recebemos
o respaldo disso recebemos as respostas
isso então é muito comum uma circular
vamos nos dias posteriores à intervenção
nas áreas de ação e colhermos
anonimamente sem dizemos que fomos nós
que fizemos aquilo as impressões as
pessoas em relação àquele e ultimamente
as respostas tem os itens que nós
estamos no caminho do bem ultimamente as
respostas dizem que é
a agitação do seu visível bem formada
nas artes apoiaria nossas ideias
obrigado a
E aí